I hate intros attack on Titan season 3
most of the gang are reunited and make
up the new Levi squad they're all
staying together in a cabin isolated
from everybody else eden has been
practicing transforming and controlling
his side he's trying to learn how to get
hard so he can plug the hole in Moorea
pedo nick is the one who revealed
caduceus identity is this thirty of ace
and he said that she might know more
secrets about the wall pedo nick dies
and Zoe thinks it was the military
police who tortured and killed him
because he was working with the scouts
and revealed this information they're
then forced to leave because military
police put a freeze on all Scout
activity and raid the cabin shortly
after they flee Levi's squad end up
heading over to trust history to try and
find out who's behind this odd Amina and
John poses as thought Ian hadn't and
they end up getting abducted odd Amin is
violated and it's rough on him because
we all know that he's saving himself
ahead in but I don't know I kind of ship
him with the molester are you telling me
there's no chemistry here Mikasa is
Mikasa breaks and secures them and
restrains the assailants Levi's watching
over the car carrying a tin anistar do
when he starts talking about a mass
murderer named Kenny the Ripper who
killed over a hundred soldiers Levi had
lived with him as a kid and he's
suspicious that he might be the one
behind this Levi fails his perception
check his soldiers are ambushed killed
and he comes face-to-face with Kenny
yep Assad to leave I brought some words
to a gunfight so yes a dip with Kenny
pursuing him Eden in Estonia get drugged
and wagon jacked
Kenny chases Levi into a bar where Levi
almost drops him with a gun behind the
counter because and the others rushed to
help when they hear the commotion they
run into Levi who kills another soldier
he explains that they're the enemy and
to not hesitate to kill them literally
two seconds after Jon hesitates and
nearly dies I don't mean finally does
something relevant and then cries about
it which cements my eternal hatred
toward him even though aadmi popped his
cherry they still manage to get away
with that in an Estonia Levi's squad
captured an old friend though the
brain-dead Trump supporter who blocked
the gate during the Trask evacuation
when Edmund first turned into a Titan he
ends up agreeing to help them set up
some soldiers Levi tries out torturing
people for the first time and Zoe is
here to help after being tortured and
misled saans ends up revealing that that
ace family is actually the true royal
family which is why they wanted his
store together
Kenny finds out about the Trump
supporter helping Levi so he kills put
the trump supporter son flee go leaves
was nearby and sees the others come to
the conclusion that his authority has
fought that loud must be the one behind
this and that's where they were taken
yep ax so three we come in with a bit of
backstory on his 30th she was raised on
a farm with her mom who's always reading
books I never spoke to her one day is
3006 affection from her my guess is she
wasn't reading parenting books because
her reaction wasn't exactly ideal but it
turns out his xxx kind of likes us which
makes her a masochist which makes her a
great match for Annie which makes this a
love square and I ship it all as long as
somebody's getting action because we all
know Eddins not going to with Mikasa
hanging around authority his mom finally
talked to her for the first time but I
guess I was too much small talk because
she doesn't come back for years after
wall Maria Falls she meets her father
for the first time and her mom is killed
by Kenny Kenny's gonna kill her too by
her dad suggests sending her away
instead and that's when she gets the
name could he still ends back to the
president without is explaining that
that ace family is the actual royal line
and that she's gonna be the one to save
humanity over to Zoe who explains I want
to tie and eat somebody with titan
powers like Eden or writers they revert
back to a human and they take on the
power that the victim possessed
Zoe tells Edwin about the Royal line
being fake and Edwin plants to enthrone
historia and overthrow the current
government Edwin is then framed for the
murder of the Trump supporter the last
scene is Levi's squad planning on how to
get to Adam when they hear soldiers
approaching the episode for the soldiers
approaching are actually some familiar
faces from season 1 we have the
justice-seeking Marlowe who wants to
stop corruption and Annie's roommate
hitch Ottoman is useless because that's
all he's good for it well I mean Casas
and Levi subdued
man what a shame it would be if one of
them got startled and shot I mean
him into a coma for the rest of the show
things wouldn't be the same you know
like in the best way possible Edwin is
being held in the capital and beaten for
information flagels running from the
military police and has no sense of
direction so Zoe has to save him back
over to the captives who realize the
government isn't being entirely honest
so Marlo wants to help John test them to
make sure that they're loyal and then
agrees to let them help attack a
checkpoint to get information flagel
accuses himself this bait to expose the
military police to a handful of citizens
that were loyal to his father
this makes them rally behind flake Levi
starting to get the hang of torturing
people when they hear more people coming
and in the last couple of scenes add one
is brought before the king to find out
what he's being charged with Yepez owed
five during the trial for add one he
explains that if wall rose falls in
civil war inside wall Sina is
unavoidable because of the lack of food
so they meet the scouts in order to
retake wall Maria for Humanity to have a
chance but they don't really care about
any of that they just want to kill ad
one and destroy the scouts so they
sentence him to death as they're
preparing to carry out the execution
they get word that wall burrows has been
breached
big ceeze gives the order to get the
refugees inside of wall Sina and to save
as many people as possible but the
higher-ups stop him and give the order
to shut the gates instead because of
what Edwin had just predicted about
Civil War this was actually a false
report fabricated by pixies to see how
the higher-ups would handle it because
they wanted to sacrifice the refugees
there is comes in with his soldiers to
help overthrow the government all of the
interior police are restrained by
Darius's men the people who were
approaching Levi's squad last episode
was actually Zoe to give them in the
news that they've been cleared of
charges and that they're free again back
of it added new dreams of being like
sneaky and then wakes up and what
appears to be a sex dungeon from Fifty
Shades of gay oh and it's tardy is there
too episode six his thirty and her
father fondle Eden's back to release his
memories I didn't see says dad's
memories of fighting as a Titan and then
injecting yet and and turning him into a
Titan after he turned into a Titan he
ate his dad and that's how he got his
Titan powers and was able to turn back
into a human whose authority also got
memories back from her childhood over
half sister for they do caring for her
Kaneesha ed his father had eaten fat a
day to get her power and they killed the
rest of the device family now it's
assumed that this power was passed on to
Evan because he ate his death Curtis
shows up and is ordered by the base to
guard against any soldiers who come we
got some more sexual frustration that
was subliminally and possibly
subconsciously expressed Edwin gets his
soldiers together to go rescue Evan but
is too far so Levi's squad goes ahead to
stop placing Kenny we also find out that
Kenny is possibly a relative to Mikasa
because they have the same last name
sidenote because he Kenny and Levi have
all had power spikes like when we cos he
kills the kidnapper attacking at it as a
child
dr. Mann family was a vital supporter of
the king but were persecuted when they
turned their back on the king along with
the oriental clan they are some of the
few bloodlines I can't have their
memories altered by the time powers
which is why the king feared them and
have them persecuted it's also suggested
that Kenny is Levi's uncle which would
make me Qasim Levi distant relatives and
in the last scene the Levi squad is
getting ready to launch their assault
episode 7 cloud is getting ready to turn
his daughter into Italian so that she
can eat ad in and get the Titan powers
back using the smokescreen Levi's squad
breaches the caverns and engage Kenny
soldier
so ease her and gets thrown into wall
can it gets injured by leave either in
the fight so they have to fall back and
regroup Kenny over here is that the
device bloodline are the only ones who
can fully harness the Titan power so he
gets mad because he wanted to take it
and responsive as he decides to release
adding to give him a fighting chance in
states whoever wins gets a Titan power
but Eddin doesn't transform because he
wants to sacrifice himself in hopes that
his daughter will be able to save
humanity his authority asked why they
didn't save humanity using the power
before but he claims that the only way
to know is by obtaining the memories
that come with the power I guess she's
not having any of that answer because
she breaks the serum and judo tosses the
douche across the room she goes to
release Adam but while doing this rod
leaks the serum off the ground
apparently you just need to lick a drop
I don't know why they're running around
with this big-ass syringe if that's the
case but he transforms in the last scene
yet the Saudi Levi so I can't get
through and net because Kenny soldiers
are camping the other side but they find
an opening in the roof that lets him
slip by big it's Evan and help his
daughter a game free rut Stein is
actually bigger than the colossal Titan
starts to collapse the cavern it looks
hopeless Biden uses a bottle labeled pot
armor to transform into a Titan and
hardness can create a barrier stopping
the roof and clapping on everybody they
meet up with that one and everybody goes
back to wall Cena to discuss what to do
about the massive tie and literally face
rolling toward the district they explain
everything to Zoe about how even if that
lease has the founding Titan power
inside of ed and they're still
controlled by the first kings will and
won't help humanity against the Titans
which is why ed instead stole the power
so that he could help adding liberate
humanity from the first kings well his
story's given the news that she's gonna
be coined to give the public the story
that the actual air took back the throne
from an imposter yepez owed not I didn't
know tried using his powers to control
Titans on rod Stein but it doesn't work
the soldiers use canister try and soften
the tine up which doesn't work cuz that
would be way too simple so they gather a
bunch of barrels of gunpowder to stop
instead the time reaches the wall and
looks like a brain-dead face rolling
ribbon player after a long day of solo
cube against me I don't want to explain
sex of the virgin odd I mean which leads
to the plan of having ed in shove his
barrels down the Titans throat causing
an explosion thoria finds the vital and
damages that to prevent any regeneration
has a flashback in the monologues to
everybody that she's of the Queen after
all of this Levi finds Kenny who was
nearly dead and lost all of his soldiers
in the cavern collapse
he's too injured and bound to die but he
pulls out a Titan serum in the last
scene yepez o tent we get a flashback of
young Kenny fighting against roz brother
OD OD apologizes for the Ackerman's
persecution which shocks Kenny and makes
him want to work for it again he goes to
visit his sister who worked in a brothel
but she died leaving little Levi with
nowhere to go Kenny took him in and
taught him how to survive in the
underground then once he could fend for
himself he leaps so he becomes ill which
is when he passes his power on to his
niece fade back to the present Kenny
tells Levi that the Ackerman's oppose
the king because he didn't
my humanity to survive gives Levi the
serum and then passes away over to his
door dia who's crowned the new queen and
most people seem to support her
meanwhile rhinos armored Titan had just
suffered a defeat to the Beast tine and
we get a first look at the person
piloting the beast ein episode 11
since eden learned how to get hard they
can use his powers to set up traps to
kill Titans without anybody having to
fight I didn't remembers that when he
was saying his dad's memories he saw
Keith shot at these who was the one who
trained them they all go to talk to
Keith to find out what he knows he
explains that he met I didn't dad
outside the wall and brought him inside
Grisha couldn't remember anything but
his name and that he's a doctor
Tyler once tine is found and killed by
Keith right before he gets cooked by
Grisha when he marries Eden's mom who
Keith was in love with when while Maria
Falls he helps get he should find Eden
and they both learn about Eden's mom
this is what makes Keyshia want to pass
the power on to a Dinn so that he can
avenge his mom Keith tried to follow
them but only found a head and passed
out and carried him back to the shelter
side note the reason a dense gear had
malfunction and training was because
Keith had tampered with it but it was
clear that wasn't gonna be enough to
stop at it episode 12 edwin decides to
entrust the serum Kenny had with Levi
and tells them that they're counting on
him did decided when to use it
Levi tries talking Edwin into setting
out the mission to retake wall Maria but
gets shot down the rest is pretty much
filler content then talking about the
last four months since a colossal teens
second appearance John and Edden get
into a fight Levi finishes it the last
couple of scenes are the public actually
showing support to the scouts for the
first time in a long time as well as the
official launch of the mission to retake
wall marina
you
I don't want to size the truck we had
with Levi and tells him that all Maria
but his that 30 Oh Kenny tells them to
oh you want to use it Levi try said I
got him to use this no to on him to
decide when to use it
the rest is pretty much filler content
I've been talking about the last 4
months in this ed what is it Levi's try
sake names a little every day because I
got to go Edwin decides to entrust the
serum Kenny had with Levi and tells him
that they're counting on him they
decided when to use it
Levi tries talking adilyn into sitting
out the mission to retake wall Maria but
gets shot down the rest is pretty much
filler content then talking about the
last 4 months since the colossal tines
second appearance John and Edun get into
a fight Levi finishes it the last couple
of scenes are the public actually
showing support to the scouts for the
first time in a long time as well as the
official launch of the mission to retake
wall Maria